what is the church's status on this
public university and the answer is it
has no status whatsoever because it's
not connected in any way shape or form
because it's on its own land that is
just nearby to the public university
[Music]
there's been a movie franchise that I've
been putting off reacting to because of
all of the theological and philosophical
implications So today we're going to
talk about God's Not Dead 3 a light in
the darkness with none other than
Michael from wisebrack thanks so much
for being here Michael I'm so glad to be
here if ever there is a movie I wanted
to watch and talk about with you
for whatever reason this would be the
one all right well For Better or Worse
let's dig into God's not dead three oh I
can't wait we're seeing more and more
protests around the city since local
Pastor David Hill was arrested for
contempt of court Hill refused to abide
by a controversial government mandate to
turn over transcripts of his sermons to
City officials if we're looking at this
news report uh that is potentially a
summary from the local news that is the
name of the website Reverend David Hill
pastor of local St James Church was
arrested Monday after refusing to abide
by a controversial government mandate
for all Hope Springs religious leaders
to turn over their sermons to government
officials for review many are accusing
the state of overstepping its bounds
yeah you think claiming they are on a
Witch Hunt to silence
silent religious leaders to silence
religious leaders as I think what they
meant for making political statements
from the pulpit okay they didn't grammar
check the local news article I mean this
is why local news is dying well I mean
doesn't that violate some sort of church
State religion yeah different things so
the only thing that this could possibly
be related to is What's called the
Johnson Amendment which it's not a
mandate against churches being political
it is that if you explicitly get into
politics then you potentially lose your
status as a non-profit okay so
effectively everything the church does
would then be taxable no one's going to
like the IRS police aren't going to come
around and force you to turn over your
sermon uh that's just not a thing wow so
I've learned a lot and I've also learned
that there's no fact Checker at the Hope
Springs local news now a contentious and
heated Free Speech debate is threatening
to boil over while the pastor sits in
jail waiting for a ruling
the fact that Ted McGinley was in this
too is crazy
[Music]
you know I mean it's almost like uh and
I would never accuse the filmmaker of
this uh they wanted to Gin up the idea
that uh Christians in America are under
attack it's almost like all of these
movies are operating with that
fundamental assumption I don't think
that's the case I would never accuse the
filmmaker of that it's the baggage that
I'm bringing into this yes uh that
they're taking on a persecution complex
foreign
down by presumably his one night is
spent by himself hey dude
I mean the conditions that we're seeing
in the jail are so much better than your
average like accused is going to be in
in the U.S well they probably kept him
in solitary because of the risk he posed
what do you have to say about being
released today I am grateful to the
court that they recognize that this
mandate was unconstitutional
look okay
is it a mandate is it a subpoena is it
something unrelated that he actually was
found in contempt of court for like is
the church protected from Criminal
investigations is it possible that they
might have to disclose things uh you
know related to speech this is a really
interesting exercise of the different
parts of the First Amendment and I can't
wait to see how they resolve all of
these issues this is more of a human
rights issue it's about our right to see
truth and to share that truth with
others but considering your church is
associated with a public university how
do you define truth exactly okay
how is this church associated with a
public university to the extent that
there is a formally recognized or
formerly Associated church with a public
university that probably doesn't pass
mustard but I I gotta know the answer to
that question to be able to understand
anything else that's going on in this
movie they'll tell us for sure I'd
completely trust them I'm sure yeah
truth is a person
the person of Jesus Christ
it's the one truth of all others what do
you have to say to the people here Jesus
Christ is the one truth really this guy
just can't help himself can he a couple
of things here uh not strictly speaking
legal but I'd like your take on this
number one the pastor gets out of jail
and the first question he's presented
with is how do you define truth exactly
just a totally normal question for a
reporter to ask if only journalists
would Corner people and say like hey
what's your epistemological framework or
you know really getting to the bottom of
it I would be on board with that I think
that's a great thing I encourage any
reporters watching to start doing that
um no it's a really weird thing to ask
on top of it this is a Christian Pastor
somewhere in Middle America
and he says probably the most Anodyne
thing I can possibly imagine a pastor
saying and it's national news like this
guy can't help himself he's talking
about religion there's a comment here so
we're looking at I think a fake
um Facebook stream yeah and Brandi Lynn
said what would you expect a pastor to
say yes Brandy thank you look it's not
it's not super weird right freedom of
worship in places of worship but Hedley
is a State University see and that's the
question y'all what's the church doing
on a State campus in the first place
that is a good question as the battle
rages on in hope the Historic Landmark
that has served this community for over
a century and now they want the church
gone this is what our country has come
to
it's a slow look back
the Supreme Court especially more
recently has allowed public funds to
flow to religious organizations and
especially his carved out exceptions
where there's long-standing Traditions
the court tends to bend over backwards
to find an exception that says it's not
really religious it's more about history
maybe this church has been on public
grounds for years and years yeah maybe
it pre-dates the construction of the
campus around it maybe
what was that I don't know
[Music]
this looks like relatively Petty
vandalism you got a kid who has spray
painted a single X on the sign and he is
throwing a brick through the window of a
church this appears to be religiously
motivated so there is technically a
federal
anti-hate crime law that does make it a
federal crime to destroy a religious
property on the basis of religions
are we meant to believe the rock goes
through the window and then magically
hits the valve on a gas pipe that's
connected to nothing I mean so here's
one question
the person the young man college student
presumably baseball player who threw the
brick through the window right right has
inadvertently presumably killed a man
yes would it be easy to get him on
murder for that no okay no within the
pantheon of homicide you have you know
intentional murders where I literally
specifically intend to kill you yeah
then you have things like uh
manslaughter negligent homicide where
someone dies in the course so generally
something that is reckless or inherently
dangerous there's the felony murder rule
where you are committing an inherently
dangerous crime and during the
commission of that crime someone dies
you are guilty of first-degree murder
because you did something that you
should have known would would kill
someone here
he has thrown a brick through a window
uh and through a Rube Goldberg series of
events uh an explosive light bulb went
off that combusted the rest of the gas
this this kid doesn't have the specific
intent necessary for murder yeah or even
the kind of negligence that would be
necessary for a manslaughter the law
looks to what your intent was in
determining your level of of culpability
or guilt I do Wonder though
um could his next of kin the estate of
Jude could they sue the manufacture of
the light bulb or the manufacturer of
the the gas valve I mean seemed to be
some some major uh manufacturing defects
that led to this Rube Goldberg of death
yes also seems like poor maintenance on
behalf of Saint James Church if I was
going to sue someone on behalf of Jude
or Jude's estate uh I would I would
probably sue the light bulb manufacturer
I'd probably sue the gas valve
manufacturer and probably sue the church
to get recompense for for this person
that has died this is absurd they can
just take the church from us wait don't
we own this land yes so how is this
legal eminent domain
I studied property a lot in grad school
as I understand the state gave all
public universities complete autonomy
over eminent domain can we studied it a
bit no just a bit of property law in
grad school wow as one does okay so we
finally have an answer what is the
church's status on this public
university and the answer is it has no
status whatsoever because it's not
connected in any way shape or form
because it's on its own land that is
just nearby to the public university the
church owns the land this doesn't
involve the first amendment in any way
because the church owns this land uh the
public university is going to try to use
what's called eminent domain where you
know a government entity can take over
land to repurpose it for some other yes
that's like when houses get knocked down
to build a new freeway exactly right
exactly right now it is the case that uh
sometimes churches have been subject to
public domain and it is also the case
that sometimes public universities these
have more or less the power to engage in
eminent domain the the private entity is
entitled to the fair market value of the
property that has been taken if the
university had a good faith uh you know
non-anti-religious reason for taking
over this property then it could
probably do so
that's Church
it's hard to even recognize it
hey look this is a property law case
it's not really my thing here's you're a
social justice attorney is that a thing
uh theoretically there are civil rights
lawyers Social Justice attorney I've
never heard that term before okay yeah
that's what I was wondering you would
want someone who specializes in property
law property law is is very complex uh
there's a lot of ins and outs you would
want someone who has that built-in
institutional knowledge you would you
would definitely not want to hire this
guy what's the classic movie move right
that someone knows a lawyer they don't
specify what their area is and they're
magically able to do the thing yeah of
course now I'm able to do that but other
people maybe not let me get this
straight you drive all the way up here
you don't even call were you afraid I'd
say no
I don't even know what you'd say to be
honest
look I have a little money
I want your money
this is a legit offer then goes the
trial jury probably give you half that
amount less even
money aside these things always get
messy he just established he doesn't
know anything about property law but
he's willing to opine that this is a
good offer you should take it the jury
might give you half of that so
well so for trial you're risking that
and you're paying for representation so
yes okay oh if you go to trial you're
going to have to pay your attorney it's
very rare that you get attorney's fees
from the other side yeah so you might
spend hundreds of thousands of dollars
to get less than hundreds of thousands
of dollars back in an increased amount
of money God called me to fight
on a fight
God calls you you call me
you called me to fight is has
n't worked out well there's you know in
in the New Testament we refer to Christ
as the Prince of Peace so you could also
take that route there's like turn the
other cheek there's a lot of evidence
that maybe the move isn't too to do a
holy war but whatever Reverend Dave
thinks he needs to do let me know what
what's going on you know what's up
excuse me excuse me
stop stop I need you on the other side
of the tape sir I'm the pastor of this
church well that may be but it's not
safe it's okay I'm his attorney
congratulations and I'm a Mets fan now
what that's a great line I like that hey
buddy I have a demo permit you got a
permit to wreck the church on Sunday
really yeah what can I say signed by the
president of the University
uh uh wait okay I don't think the
president of the university is ever
going to be able to sign off on a demo
permit there's been absolutely no time
for the eminent domain process too it
worked at this point unless there is
some ordinance that says if there is a
burned down building it just has to be
demolished and and that would have no
effect on the eminent domain thing it
would have no effect on the church's
ability to rebuild this is presumably I
think we have to believe it's because
this church is going to fall down and
kill someone yeah and it looks like it's
going to
your honor I am so sorry do do not do
this this is 100 improper
I'm aware it's it's very timely it
involves a church I have a signed
injunction from Judge Pasquale that says
well you can read it yourself cease and
desist uh if you talk to the judge
without opposing counsel present uh
generally that is a gross violation of
both court rules and ethics rules that's
an ex-party communication so you can't
do stuff like this where you talk to the
judge alone let alone on Sunday in a
church in a private setting all of
that's improper now there is a more
fundamental problem if you can even
believe it which is that there isn't a
lawsuit here judges and lawyers it's not
like you can just find a random judge on
the street and say hey write an
injunction for me like there are limited
situations where you can get emergency
ex part a relief
um but even that takes
48 Hours usually oh and
so an injunction is the thing that you
get at the end of a case it is the the
final remedy that stops or forces
someone to do something man I don't have
to find a new film series to learn about
the law from guess so
Barbara we appreciate it it's very
courteous I get it it's a prime piece of
land
you know what I do if it were me I'd put
in a big Student Center with a fancy
coffee shop the kids would love it I
mean to me that's more valuable than a
Dusty old church no offense but he knows
how I feel about it here's the problem
what you're doing it's against the law
because eminent domain doesn't
automatically apply just because you
guys don't like his church
so here's my counter
withdraw your claim or we Sue oh a
lawsuit over eminent domain
we're done
already laid the foundation for why
eminent domain would apply in this case
the school is theoretically not seizing
this property because of anti-religious
fury because they don't like the church
they're doing it because they want to
expand the campus so it's a question of
valuation did they fairly compensate the
church for the land that they took Josh
you're a smart kid once you give up on
Law School
I wouldn't say give up on it
um once I spent time on a college campus
I realized there was a real need there
you know Ministry just another way for
me to serve what kind of law were you
studying same as you civil rights social
justice really because you don't strike
me as a liberal you're the kid did you
go to law school or not what do you
think that your religious beliefs get in
the way of real social change no my my
beliefs are the foundation of change the
belief that every human is made in the
image of God I mean Jesus was the
ultimate social justice Warrior
he said the lives of children mattered
and regarded women with honor and
dignity in a cultural moment where a
woman's testimony wasn't even
permissible in a court of law well I've
been doing this a long time and I wish
I'd seen those words put into action
more often yeah me too
we're all responsible for our part but
it's Grace and then Justice amen
let's say grace
let's eat his pizza
like what Josh admits here but it's
confusing right because he calls Jesus
the original social justice Warrior but
I have to wonder who that line in this
movie is geared for because the people I
think that enjoy these movies probably
chafe at the term social justice Warrior
and to characterize Jesus as a social
justice Warrior the first social justice
Warrior seems like it's going to rub the
people that watch this movie the wrong
way so it's interesting to have this
like internal critique within the film
because the films again are representing
this world where it seems like
Christianity is about like laws
institutions
um codifying beliefs in the sort of
objective way and you have cool guy Josh
saying no it's about like living a life
of Grace and Justice and all this sort
of stuff so I mean like you said why is
it there at the same time I think it's
the one little
morsel of an interesting read on the
function of religious religion we
condemn the hateful actions
of Adam Richardson in the strongest
possible terms we've taken the immediate
steps to expel Mr Richardson and we have
encouraged the state to prosecute him to
the fullest extent of the law okay they
have no power to do any of that the
church is on its own property that's why
they had to try to take it in the first
place for through evident domain and
then
you can't make a recommendation to the
prosecutor to prosecute someone like
you're just a stranger to this whole
thing well it's like now that it's
convenient to him he's like yes the
church which we are a part of that we
own because the university and the
church coexists in a symbiotic way get
off the campus that you're not on yeah
not good yeah and I like how they use
that to make them look like they're good
guys for a second but again weird
overlapping spheres man I'm so sorry
about Jude I am so
sorry
if I am withdrawing my lawsuit against
the school he's dropping the charges no
you don't get to do that
the state prosecutes someone the the
district attorney will decide whether to
continue Prosecuting someone or not
a victim even and he's a tangentially
related victim uh yeah they don't get to
decide whether uh charges are dropped or
not yeah it seems like the logic he's
using there is like if someone comes
into my house and kills my friend I can
be like no no it's my house yeah so I'd
like to drop that yeah no just don't
prosecute him I I have forgiven him he
can go free now we just ended up where
we were in in the beginning we took a
long journey to get to him saying like
fine take the church this is the most
self-defeating movie I think I've ever
watched he just used legal services of
his cool guy brother for months with no
compensation whatsoever he's dropped his
entire living practice to prosecute this
thing that's the real victim this cool
guy brother okay so now we have to give
this movie a grade for legal realism
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it just occurred to me that they haven't
resolved any of the First Amendment
issues at all I forgot that that's what
this movie was about they did use some
legal terms correctly eventually we did
learn that eminent domain was the thing
that they had to use uh other than that
uh a lot of inaccuracies never talk to
the judge outside of the Court
proceedings I'm going to give this one a
solid D room for improvement that's not
bad if you give someone a d they they
still have a chance in the class they
still pass they still pass yeah we're
giving it passing grade just so we never
have to watch it again if you want to
see Michael take on the philosophical
aspects of this movie to the extent of
their RNA check out our collaboration
over here if you want to see more legal
eagle check out this video over here or
I'll see you in court